etwas glauben jetzt willkommen beim
neuen video und ich merke ich bin dumm
weil ich habe einen pulli an und es ist
draußen obwohl es regnet hier drin ist
es noch wärmer als draußen ich könnte
jetzt die garantien aber ich hatte mir
noch 15 minuten zeit für dieses video
ohne wird in 15 minuten wollte ich beim
kollegen vermögen das schaffe ich eh
nicht egal alex alles gut alles
entspannt muss er halt warten und zwar
habe ich mir für heute natürlich wieder
was ganz spezielles überlegt was er auch
noch nie gehabt weil vor allem die erste
voll also hat auf jeden fall die erste
folge davon ist kraft gut angekommen
dies kräftig ab gegangen hat glaube ich
schon 600 tausend klicks oder so und
zwar war es die dümmsten photoshop
gehört und ihr habt mir danach wirklich
noch ganz viele andere dumme photoshop
girls geschickt also diese sachen wo
irgendwelche mädchen irgendwas mit
photoshop machen und dann das haben er
kann nicht wieder einen roten kreis
drauf war heute passt es auch ja ich
will gar nicht lange lagern stelle ich
die vor wenn ihr noch bock habt auf eine
dritte folge dann schickt mir weitere zu
und ihr könnt gerne jetzt schon mal
daumen nach oben da lassen dann sehe ich
das ja und wir fangen direkt an jetzt
muss jetzt um ihr handy holen und zwar
mir die laura dieses bild geschickt wo
ich erst mal gerade genauer hinsehen
musste weil ich hab gedacht auf diesem
bild befinden sich halt auch keine roten
kreise wo man das schneller erkennt auf
jeden fall habe ich dann auf den boden
gespuckt und euch ist es wahrscheinlich
direkt aufgefallen mir halt nicht sorry
die ist eigentlich gar also die hat
eigentlich gar nicht so ein arsch also
oben hat sie das war arbeite so lohnt
nicht gut
mädchen wenn man das macht dann immer
genauer hinschauen immer genau hingucken
alles nochmal überdenken
obwohl das ist auch schon mega thumm das
könnte auch fast extra sein weil zu dumm
ist egal wir machen weiter mit dem
nächsten fehler
und zwar wechsel ich kurz die seite da
ist der rote kreis jetzt überflüssig
wenn man das so mal anschaut es fällt
auch sofort auf wie stehen sie da wo sie
darum stellt man sich so hin man kann
sich doch normal einstellen das sieht
viel besser aus
auf jeden fall das liegt perfekt so aus
als wäre der schrank extra so gemacht um
da halt die brüste von diesem mädchen
rhein zu platzieren
hey leute was wir gerade aufhält guckt
euch mal diesen teddybären an der guckt
genau darauf wahrscheinlich denkt er
sich horst die sind aber klein der krass
meinte das wird auch mit frisch
im nachhinein noch bearbeitet oder das
war echt so wenn es echt zu warten dann
ist das wirklich ein witziges bild egal
wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten bild
und zwar ist dass dieses bild wo ich mir
nur denken kann
die hat sich wirklich photoshop für
downloaded und sich nicht ein tutorial
angeguckt sondern irgendwas gedrückt und
dann kam das bei um ich meine wie so
stellt man sich erstens da so hin dass
ich voll unnatürlich und zweitens ich
versteh gar nicht was es gebracht haben
sollte es hat einfach gar nicht so gut
aussah unten halt dass sie fliesen
falsch liegen und seinen bizeps am
platzen aber das war es auch
oder übrigens ist das das erste video
seit langem wo ich mal wieder richtig
zufrieden bin mit meinen haaren auf
jeden fall kommen wir zunächst viel was
ich das wüsste ich auch nicht wird euch
das mal an so und was ist da jetzt
anders es kann halt nur sein die tür ist
schief aber das ist einfach auf kopfhöhe
wollte die irgendwie in kopf oder machen
oder so oder sehe ich hier gerade
irgendwas nicht weil die hat ja echt
schon in dünnen bau also eine dünne teil
wie es das teil ihr teil ja keine ahnung
also das einzige was ich diesem bild
entnehmen kann ist dass sie paris ganz
schön findet wenn ihr das check dann
schreibt zwar in die kommentare
das ist ganz schön versteckt glaube ich
okay wahrscheinlich denke ich nur es ist
versteckt und es ist ich fand schon ein
bisschen versteckt und dann kommen wir
natürlich auch schon zum letzten bild
oder was wir haben wir jetzt 56 ja keine
ahnung auf jeden fall ist es dieses bild
was mir erstmal so auffällt dass sie
wirklich natürlich aus wer der
hintergrund jetzt normal
dann wird man es überhaupt nicht checken
so aber das haus stürzt hat fast ein
oder ist es ein bisschen schief gebaut
was eventuell darauf hindeutet dass die
linke brust etwas vergrößert wurde auch
und danke übrigens für den gelben pfeil
den habt ihr wunderbar mit paint dahin
gemalt oder ich weiß nich gibt's noch
ein schlechteres programm als das weil
ich schlecht
das geht besser aber ansonsten finde ich
so diese frau hat wirklich potenzial was
anstreben einer zukünftigen karriere
also ich finde die wirklich ganz hübsch
oder schönen photoshop ist vielleicht
nicht ganz so dein thema aber möchte ich
einfach bei mir beim nächsten bild dann
bin ich mir sicher ich hol dir da so
richtig schön was raus und dann bist du
richtig fasziniert von mir und finde es
mich wahrscheinlich auch ach wir lassen
ja wie gesagt was waren das jetzt also
schreibt mir einfach oder schickt mir
weitere photoshop girls wenn ihr welche
findet einfach bei mir auf instagram
instagram steht und in der video
beschreibung war auch eben eingeblendet
oder jetzt keine ahnung ansonsten hoffe
ich dieses video hat euch gefallen
wie gesagt wenn ihr noch mehr sehen
wollt das mache ich jetzt schon wieder
der lasten daumen nach oben da freut
mich sehr ich wünsche euch einen
traumhaften sonntag abonnieren nicht
vergessen um nicht überlassen wir sehen
uns dann nächste woche dienstag oder so
denke ich wieder da kommen coole neue
videos jede woche jetzt vier videos
schätze ich mal so gut
haut rein das habe ich schon vor lange
nicht mehr gemacht weil ich ich will
jetzt los haut rein chem